it's great to welcome back to the
program ben burgess who's a philosophy
professor at georgia state university
perimeter college also
author of the book give them an argument
logic for the left ben has joined us
before
uh appreciate your time ben well thanks
for having me again
so i've been talking to my audience
about a concern of mine which is that
i'm seeing some who
maybe in times past had a pretty clearly
defined set of policy ideas that they
found important sometimes they'd be
socially democratic policy ideas some
are actual
socialists um and i've seen
the focus on the policy sort of replaced
or preempted in some cases
by a rhetoric that we would define as
populist
and as people like federico finkelstein
for example have written about
extensively
that rhetoric often sounds very similar
on the left
and on the right and can sometimes be
used to sort of
separate uh people from a defined set of
policy ideas and sometimes in the worst
of cases
people end up supporting candidates
whose policy ideas when it comes right
down to it are really antithetical to
to where they started i let's open it
there
is this a concern that you share if so
how are you seeing it manifest if not
where where am i wrong i know that's
absolutely a
concern that i i'd share i mean i think
like populism might be most helpfully
thought of
as a rhetorical style you know there's
the people
and there's some sort of elite you know
that you're counter posing the people to
and there's nothing wrong with that
rhetorical style that's that's how
a lot of uh people that i like would
frame things you know that's that's uh
that's how bernie sanders talks
uh but it's also rhetorical style that
you could use
in service of all kinds of different
uh political agendas um you know there's
certainly lots of right-wing versions of
it
uh and it's it's in itself
uh that's kind of empty right that that
doesn't actually tell you much of
anything
uh about whether somebody is going to do
things that you'd like
uh in terms of in terms of policy
whether they're
they're even really on the same side of
you as you are in terms of policy
yeah one of the one of the sort of
corporate media
players that has really benefited from
the use of this rhetoric i think is fox
news is tucker carlson who will often
frame a lot of issues as
uh it's it's the people maybe against
corporations it's the people against
elites it's the people against whoever
but then he'll say he he'll warn you you
know make sure black lives matter
doesn't take your house or or whatever
and the solutions are very nationalistic
often xenophobic
is this new i mean it seems to me that
even if you go back to earlier 20th
century europe
there are examples of populist rhetoric
being used and it's sort of maybe not
that clear whether we're talking about
left or right populism and
it is sort of a gateway to some pretty
severe authoritarianism yeah no i mean
that could certainly be true
although i guess the point that i'd
really emphasize as far as tucker goes
is that um you know look it's
it's possible like there's nothing
that's that's impossible there's nothing
you can just
rule out about the idea that you could
have somebody
who really did have some creepy right
wing ideas about immigration or
something else
who really could have some degree of
redistributionism about economics
you know i think they're global examples
that i think they're historical examples
of
of that kind of thing uh but in his case
i think that like the creepy right wing
ideas about immigration are real
and the economic populism is pretty
hollow
uh so he does talk like that right he
he'll criticize corporations for their
lack of economic patriotism he'll he'll
even criticize them sometimes for paying
low wages
but then the obvious follow-up question
is okay so if the wages are too low
should we support
raising the minimum wage should we
change labor laws so it's easier for
uh people you know amazon warehouses to
unionize
and that every other shoe never quite
drops he never really supports any of
that stuff
what's the prototypical example of what
you alluded to where where
in theory you could be sort of on the
right but still support a sort of
redistributive economic populism
who would we look to as an example of
that yeah
uh i think that there are i think
that certainly there are right wing and
even fascist parties
uh in europe that certainly support more
of that stuff than
that anybody like tucker carlson or josh
howley or any of these other
alleged american right populists
um you know like the sort of you know
national front types in france places
like that that uh
you know granted uh they're operated in
a very different context where a lot of
that stuff is already just sort of part
of
the uh part of the accepted consensus
it's already happened right so of course
they're gonna
of course they're gonna support it and
on some level that might not even mean
much because you think okay
sure and like british tourists say they
support keeping the nhs
uh but they do sometimes at least
uh at least appeal uh to uh to saying
that uh that you know that they would
even increase you know maybe certain
sorts of social spending you know if
they were in power
uh and of course who knows what they
would actually do if they're in power
but i i guess the point that i'd really
want to emphasize
is that this is something that you you
really don't get
right in the in the american equivalent
uh
of most of these people that uh that
they're really
you know it really isn't the case like
you know like like when somebody like uh
like steve bannon
talks about um anything that he wants to
do economically that would break from
republican orthodoxy
like once you really start digging into
the details right you know because some
of it
like you know he says things like
deconstruct the administrative state
that sounds sort of vaguely radical and
then
you think more about there like wait a
second do you just mean what everybody
else in your party means by deregulation
uh and small government etc
yeah right and you start to dig into
what he means and i think like
maybe it's like you know if bannon had
totally gotten his way in the trump
administration maybe we'd be
raising the top marginal tax rate to
something closer to what was in the
clinton years and like spend some of the
money on infrastructure spending
but then you ask obvious like questions
about okay but like
there are tens of millions of people who
don't have health care are we gonna do
medicare for all
or are we going to um
you know eliminate tuition at public
universities
or are we gonna raise the minimum wage
to 15
an hour uh and and that's not something
i ever see the bannons or the carlsons
or the hell is the world really getting
behind
can you talk a little bit about um or or
i guess maybe to frame this up
there there's some interesting
scholarship about how
there's a link between um populism
and totalitarianism and sometimes as
soon as you broach that people will say
are you saying populists are dictators
no no that's not that's not the
allegation that's being made
but can you talk a little bit about what
that link is and where the overlap
actually exists and what the limits of
that are
yeah i mean i think that uh
there is a sense like there's at least
one sense which i want to push back on
this a little bit because
uh because i think that something that
you often you often get from from
centrist certainly
uh is this way you know this sort of
habit
of demonizing
populism in general
uh and and using that word maybe even as
a way
of kind of associating like good
benevolent social democrats
you know like like bernie sanders uh
with with people who
are right-wing populists who uh who are
more likely to have these authoritarian
tendencies
and really i mean like what i'm kind of
criticized when i say hey don't fall for
tucker carlson's alleged economic
populism
is the flip side of that right people
who say yeah these things are good
and like there's some commonality there
right that i really don't think there is
uh but but you know i i do think it's
it's it's true
that if you think that the the status
quo is very bad
uh that you do set up some sort of
opposition between the people
and some kind of hostile elite right you
know that they're that that certainly
that certainly can go in an
authoritarian direction i mean it's it
it's not
um i mean as as we're uh
as for having this conversation donald
trump who often appeals to those things
just
floated a trial balloon on twitter about
delaying the presidential election
yes uh so so it's not like those sorts
of concerns are just coming out of
nowhere you know that they're totally
unfounded
uh but but i but where i would hold the
line is that i think you can
have um you can have very positive
left-wing movements that use that use
populist framing
uh that that really they really don't
have those authoritarian tendencies
and and really what i want to do uh
is is to separate these right that like
when we're just talking about populism
whether we have whether we put a plus
next to it or a minus next to it
yes uh that the danger is that we end up
conflating these things that really
don't have a lot in common with each
other
when you look at the the candidacy of
somebody like bernie sanders
as an example just to sort of think
about it um
do do you in retrospect do you think
that
the campaign had the right balance of
rhetoric and policy do you think that
if it did that there was something in
terms of how it was received or
understood that maybe was a missing link
or or like where
where do you think that balance was when
it comes to what you would like to see
in order to keep
clear number one that there's
that the bernie populism is is as you're
pointing out
not the type that would slide into
authoritarianism as we're talking about
but at the same time that it is not
removed from a specific set of policy
ideas
yeah i mean i i think that that whatever
the you know the many problems may have
been
um you know with with that movement and
and obviously you know something went
wrong right you know because because bag
you know because
not very many months ago uh the
entire mainstream discussion was about
whether uh
if birdie showed up at the democratic
convention with only a plurality of
delegates you know
should he still be the nominee yeah and
uh and it turned out that that wasn't
the problem
um but uh but i i certainly don't think
that being
you know light on policy detail was ever
really the the issue there i mean i
think i think there were always
you know it was always very good that
way right you know uh i think that
um and certainly
you know the the kind of of of rhetoric
uh about opposing interests was was good
in in my view right i mean like you you
should
uh you should point out that this isn't
just something
that's like a sort of weird coincidence
that uh
something like medicare for all has
pulled as well as it has for as long as
it has and it's and it's so marginal
uh in in terms of its you know chances
of becoming
reality politically uh that that there
is that there are structural reasons for
this
uh that you know that makes sense to me
uh i think that i think that may be part
of the problem
you know i don't want to let the bernie
campaign off the hook
for you know mistakes that they
undoubtedly you know
undoubtedly did me make i mean you know
the proof is in the pudding right they
lost but
uh i i also think that that part of the
reason that you do sometimes get this
confusion part of the reason you do get
people who are even like uh like bernie
trump swing voters
which you know has been exaggerated
right you know it's there are
fewer of those certainly than there were
um you know hillary mccain swing voters
in 2008
but um but it is also true that there
are people who would have voted for for
ruby and you know who ended up voting
for trump and there are people who
uh there are people who who i think
would be receptive
to a bernie message who who end up like
watching tucker carlson and not along
with everything that he says
and i think that the the reason for that
is
is bigger than any mistakes that that
bernie people may have made in 2016 or
2020
uh because because what bernie was
speaking to
was was this this kind of larger hunger
for um for for some kind of message that
that identified the sense that a lot of
people have of reality you know that
they that they
that the game is rigged against them
that uh that there's
uh that uh that we're not just sort of
having this neutral policy discussion
about what the you know what the best
way to go about solving these problems
is
uh that they're that uh that politics is
catering to
to the interests of a relatively small
minority of the population and many many
issues right
and and that's that's not a that's not a
sense that people have that's that's
wrong right you know
that's that's right uh and i think that
when there are so few people who are who
are really speaking to it
uh and you know especially in a
relatively effective you know
uh compelling way that it does make some
sense
that people would be a little bit of a
cheap date about it you know that
uh that like that all it takes is tucker
carlson going on fox
and talking about how american workers
have gotten a raw deal and uh uh
and and saying some bad stuff about jeff
bezos
and you know that a lot of people could
hear that and say
hey there's this there's somebody who's
telling it like it is he must be on
their side
and then you sort of don't like if
you're
if you're happy about that right you're
happy to have that spoken to
then you sort of it's it's way too
easy to miss the fact that
when it comes to what concretely to do
about this
right other than you know um then
this kind of cruel strict enforcement of
immigration laws
uh and kind of going back to historic
republic protection of republican
protectionism right like uh
yeah pretty sure from the 1850s to the
1950s the republican party was
uh more protectionist than trump is now
right and nobody mistook them for
uh for for champions of ordinary people
at the expense
of american business interests uh
that like if that's that's all he's
saying or like there's a famous
there's a famous segment where where
tucker is praising
uh something elizabeth ward said about
economic patriotism
and i i and people have pointed that out
to me often you know in the course of
these discussions like hey look at
look at how uh you know there's this
some convergence between you know
between
you know the right and you know the
moderate left on this you know that he's
praising this economic statement
uh by elizabeth warren but uh but i
remember watching that
you know once you get to the end right
right the very end of it where he
actually starts talking
about policy like the only specific war
and policy items he
uh he endorses there are more
apprenticeship programs
and the government should buy american
where possible
uh which given the scale of the the
poverty
the lack of health insurance the
ridiculous wages
everything that that is the actual
discontent that he's speaking to
that's almost farcically little to
actually give people as far as
policy solutions yeah once you get to
the policy part
it completely falls apart uh we're gonna
go to a break on the
podcast tv and radio show but my full
conversation with ben will will be on
our youtube channel
so i i want to get your thoughts on um
the election that's coming up in a very
particular context which is
it's often popular to say this is the
most important election of our lifetime
and in some sense the next one is always
the most important
because it's the next one but there's a
feeling
that i did not have in 2012 for example
when barack obama was running for
re-election and mitt romney was running
against him and yes they had different
economic policies
but it it felt like the economy by
traditional measures was going to
continue being pretty solid for the
following four years
it didn't seem nearly as consequential
as this one does uh in terms of setting
the direction of the country in a way
where
there could be more irreversible damage
done if donald trump gets another four
years
that's the context that i'm looking at
at this election through and i'm
wondering
whether you would agree partially agree
or where you are on that
yeah i mean i think it is i think it is
pretty consequential
um what what makes it a little bit hard
to make that argument is as you kind of
alluded to
uh so many progressives have cried wolf
on this
uh so many times right you know that uh
you know we've heard so many times this
election that election is is the most
important election ever
i've heard so many times that you know i
made
you know i i that uh
you know george bush is a fascist you
know nixon was a fascist right you know
that like
that that those things start to ring uh
to rig a little bit hollow
uh and and it really is
and it really is possible even now right
like
like now that trump's doing stuff like
uh you know tweeting about delay in the
election and said did federal troops to
shove people with john mark fans
uh so so he's certainly doing his best
to uh to live up to some of that hype
right you know but it's
uh but it but it's still easy
because so many people are rightly
alarmed by trump that they that uh that
they've they've also
even when it comes to trump if they've
cried wolf on certain things they've
seen they've seen
um like played up lots of things about
trump that
didn't necessarily always turn out you
know to uh
you know to be right uh but i actually
think that
that one way to sort of see the stakes
of the election
uh is to sort of take it down a notch
and see that in terms of
actually a lot of the reasons that it
would have even been bad if mitt romney
had been elected president it's also bad
uh
that uh if if trump if trump were
elected
and some of that might you know relative
to
everything i just said same sort of low
stakes or even weird to focus on like
you know you know he he was having
people you know shoved it on marked fans
why are you talking about this kind of
nitty-gritty you know economic policy
stuff
uh but at the same time uh
it is really worth thinking about
because because if you do
want to you know do something about all
those larger problems we're talking
about in the initial
segment that you know you want to uh
that you think that we do need
some the sort of political possibility
that was represented by the bernie
movement that we do need to do something
real about
poverty and economic inequality uh then
it really is very bad that uh
that trump is for example filling the
national labor relations board with
people who want to stamp out unions that
uh that the
you know the judicial appointments
certainly reflect that i mean this this
kind of mundane stuff like that
i actually think as far as like the
long-term prospects for the left
is fairly terrifying and and i guess the
way
the way that i would frame this is
i don't think that i think that if
if if we sound really alarmist and we're
also
telling people a story about biden that
they maybe know isn't quite right
then i think that a lot of people are
are not going to respond to that and and
and they're
and and they're going to not really be
that motivated
uh to to necessarily vote because uh
because it's it's not like you know i
mean look they well can you can you
before we get too far can you talk
what would be the story i guess to be
clear what would be the story about
biden that would be the not really true
one
uh that he basically uh he basically
agrees with the left he's like maybe
just a little bit more moderate and
incremental but
he uh but uh but the
the way but like the sort of thing that
people are getting at when they use
phrases like well he's not perfect
right you know like like like hey he's
not perfect but you're still getting a
lot of what you want etc
and i would argue right i know your
perspective is but i would argue that
that
that's not quite that accurate way of
putting it and that's that's one that's
maybe even a counterproductive way of
putting it because
a lot of people who you'd have to sort
of most worry
about about not pulling that lever or
i guess checking the thing on your
mailing ballot you know for for biden
um are kind of
rightly have a sense that the
differences go a lot deeper than that
right that it's it's it's not a matter
you know binded isn't like the 10
more flawed version of
of you know bernie sanders or even
elizabeth warren right i think i think
that
uh i think that bide is somebody with
which you know certainly that
the left anybody who i think is more
meaningfully an economic populist
uh has some very deep disagreements uh
yeah i mean okay so i guess my my take
on this is
i think that saying biden's not perfect
or
he's like ten percent short of bernie is
certainly inaccurate and
counterproductive so i would completely
completely agree with you there
i do think though that there's probably
a lot of being said about biden that
doesn't really look deeply at for
example
his tax proposal which does things that
i mean again it's all context but
uncapping social security tax above 400
000
i mean that that that's very very big
and that if he were president
that's arguably unprecedented now could
he get it done
okay can any president i mean i don't
think bernie was going to get medicare
for all done and that's a different
conversation when you look at um
clean energy for example he's being
attacked by some on the left for copying
stuff from bernie when i thought that's
sort of what we wanted he's attacked by
the right because his plan is
too aggressive which i like i want a
plan that's too aggressive and okay
maybe we fall short so i guess my view
on it is
these umbrella terms like okay biden's
not perfect yeah it's meaningless and
it's counterproductive
but the more i look into the policy i
come away
oh this is more left than maybe i
thought and that
when the alternative is trump makes me
feel more confident about what the right
decision is i guess is where i would
where i would leave it
yeah i mean i guess i'd just say that um
that biden okay so so there's
there are two things you know one is
uh just how seriously to
uh to take some of these commitments uh
which i think is a question with any
candidate and the problem is if you want
to focus
on that then you're just judging
sincerity which is really tough
it it is tough but i think that you can
make some informed judgments about that
right you know by
by looking certainly at uh certainly at
people's records certainly by looking at
it like what
is kind of on a website somewhere and
what somebody really emphasizes
sure uh and and i and i'd also
and then the second thing that um is
is um is that a question not necessarily
you know what you
could get done which as you say i mean
like this there's
there are enormous obstacles right who
knows what anybody
you know would actually get done at the
end of the day yeah uh
but what what somebody would really be
motivated
to expend political capital trying to
get done uh
which which might not even be the same
thing as the first question about what
they really you know with what they
really mean right because
there might be things a politician you
know would be perfectly happy to
do if it wasn't a big deal right you
know but
uh but but wouldn't necessarily uh
prioritize right so so i mean i think
like an obvious example like with the
obama administration would be card check
right you know which is something they
talked about in 2008
and then uh and then very quickly became
a distant
memory which i don't even think is like
oh uh obama was lying
right you know when he said that he
wanted car check
uh i think he would have been totally
fine with it you know but but i think
that it was it was never something
uh it was never something that was going
to be a priority now now which specific
things or which of these boxes
uh you know for biden uh you know
i mean i think without getting too
granular
about trying to to guess that right
which is what a lot of this is anyway
you know
is is guesswork uh i also think that if
you
i also think that if you take a step
back it's like okay yeah
um even if you're pretty
cynical about a lot of this
that doesn't mean that the outcome of
the election is inconsequential
that we shouldn't care that there's no
difference that
uh the things people say you know say to
me on
on twitter or like uh uh where this like
oh it's literally not even you know harm
reduction right that's silly
yeah like like that uh because even if
you have
a pretty cynical view of this stuff
uh then it's it's still it's still the
case
that um that biden appointees
the courts to the nlrb are not going to
be trying to stamp out organized labor
that uh that you're that you're not
going to
um you know that you're not going to
have these these attempts to
get rid of the last lingering shreds of
obamacare you know that uh
uh that uh that they sort
of the sort of aggressive uh
attempts to uh to carry out a kid could
go back to theme
you know about the least meaningfully
economically populist agenda
that you could imagine right you know
that you've gotten uh for from the trump
administration
are not gonna happen and of course we
haven't even gotten into like how the
pandemic is handled or
you know something like that right uh
but and so
i i guess i guess the the point i'd make
is that you can you can think bidet is
pretty bad but still think
um okay like let's
let's say i see both of these people you
know as my enemy
and i'm gonna be fighting against both
of them on certain things for the next
four years depending on what's going to
happen
uh that doesn't mean that i can't make
strategic choices about who i would
rather be fighting about what issues
yeah i think that's very well said in
the context of sort of the movement that
that you're describing and some of their
skepticism and and sometimes getting to
that 2016 idea of
hillary or trump you know it's kind of
it's not really going to make a huge
difference
i part of this may be a
an ideological difference in terms of
incrementalism versus not i mean when i
look at what i consider to be the three
biggest eras over the last 130 40 years
of progressive advancement in the us i
look at progressive era 1890 to 1920
i look at new deal era and late 50s into
60s early 70s civil rights era
and so much you know if you go back a
lot of what happened was
the supreme court had the right makeup
to uphold
really important things in the teens and
20s and in the new deal era and civil
rights era
and etc and that seems
to be supportive of recognizing
the differences between which judges
would biden pick
versus trump but that's sort of like my
framework i guess
yeah i mean i i think the question of
judicial appointees
uh is is incredibly consequential right
no doubt about that like they that
uh that the um
i mean look that the uh the supreme
court
just very you know very recently uh even
though right they've made some like
nice socially liberal rulings that that
we both not along to you know
on on things like gay and trans rights
they uh
uh on on questions that that have to do
with the economic structure of society
uh it's been incredibly destructive that
right the supreme the supreme court
just within the last you know a couple
of years uh
eliminated uh closed shops you know in
the uh
uh in the public sector you know that uh
you know with uh with with with janus
you know that uh that's
uh eliminated uh eliminating agency fees
you know
uh to uh you know that uh which
it thus forced unions to uh
represent people that they can't be
funded by right uh
and again if you don't and so even
though
i think you know we might have a
different perspective on some of the
incremental stuff right i get very
frustrated with that conversation
sometimes because they get it by god
right like uh
uh if if we were talking about you know
workers control of the means of
production you're saying you know it's
taking a little slow right you know i'd
understand that conversation but
you know i think transitioning to
canada's healthcare system seems pretty
incremental to me you know but
uh but at the same time um
you know it's if you if you don't have
a strong organized uh
workers movement at the base right if
you don't have strong unions
then i think historically you're not
going to
get any kind of you know you're not
going to get a very successful left
politically on top uh that i and
you know it and so if you're not if
you're not paying attention to that
issue i mean i i think
a lot of the rest of it is to some
extent just kind of howling into the
wind
and uh and the appointments
matter a lot for that you know that that
again you know janus happened you know
just just in the last
in the last couple of years that's
incredibly that's incredibly destructive
you know they've
even even before that right that the
decisions about opening the floodgates
on campaign finance i mean all of these
things
um you know are are are very important
uh and and even though you know they're
you know even though there are
lots of decisions that are made by lots
of democratic appointed judges you know
that that
uh you know that i don't like at all you
know that they're they're not
they're not going to they're not going
to make decisions like that like it like
like it is actually pretty important
uh whether you have democratic appointed
judges who are going to operate within a
certain framework
as far as things like hey uh
should we basically have public sector
unions
uh that's going to be extremely
different from the kind of framework
that republican judges are going to
operate in
un unquestionably yeah and i think no no
disagreement
there it sounds like and certainly i
think with the other stuff
um the audience will will get a sense of
maybe maybe where
where we differ we've been speaking with
ben burgess who's a philosophy professor
at georgia state university perimeter
college
also author of the book give them an
argument logic for the left
ben great to see you and i so appreciate
your time
all right thank you so much david